got uh we did have some naked skies and
then some clouds just kind of started
floating in these are ahead of a system
that's going to brush by us tonight and
bring in some more clouds but we're
getting just a hint of them and i think
we may see a few extra high clouds now
coming in during the day we're just
updating the forecast a little bit lots
of 50s around the valley this morning
still some low 60s downtown the lakes at
63. we've had some northwest breezes out
at red rock and up in the spring
mountains so again look for mostly i
mean lots of good sunshine but
occasional high clouds mount charleston
in the mid 50s northwest breezes up
there today could be up to 25 miles an
hour so our cold system will retreat
from the west and pull across the plains
today headed for the east there is snow
up in the northern plains the upper
midwest chilly in denver at 23 this
morning 45 in kansas city and
unfortunately it is going to pull up
warm moist air out of the gulf and cause
possibly some severe weather in the deep
south you know the northeast has been so
cold but that front in the middle of the
country is going to push warm air right
into the east coast so they'll go from
highs near 40 to in the 60s for a day
before the cold front makes its way so
first warm air then cold air snow today
warm air tomorrow then cold again the
day after so it's real mixed bag for the
eastern half of the u.s but what's
really important is that we keep our
eyes on this line of showers and
thunderstorms
all of these areas of red are high wind
warnings and then we're looking at wind
advisories in blue but we are looking at
the strike zone to be right there from
the mid south down through the gulf
coast possible tornadoes expected
through those areas today we'll have
sunshine but see those high clouds right
there that's what we're getting just a
taste of so i think we may see some
occasional and maybe even more later in
the day 78 for the high can't complain
about that and then even up to 80s as we
welcome april on friday here's that
warming trend into the weekend with mid
80s saturday heavier cloud cover on
sunday holds back the temps just a
little bit with another system skipping
through and then even warmer next week
might even make it into the upper 80s